on va passer maintenant au quiz avec
vous Nicolas dandry alors c'est à
l'occasion de la Nuit de la lecture vous
allez nous plonger dans les écrivains
célèbres qui ont été deux passages dans
les Yvelines
à maison là-dessus
vous avez pu découvrir quelques
écrivains déjà donc dans ce reportage
bon on va voir il y a de nombreux
écrivains qui sont passés dans les
Yvelines et d'abord un certain Marcel
Alain né en 1885 qui a vécu et qui est
mort en 1969 à Saint-Germain-en-Laye il
a écrit des livres comme les mystères du
métro ou monsieur personne mais il est
surtout connu pour avoir créé son avec
son co-auteur Pierre Souvestre un
personnage emblématique de la
littérature on le connaît aussi ce
personnage parce que c'est un personnage
de film alors de quel personnage
s'agit-il
je peux vous dire non non je peux vous
dire que ce personnage et bien on le
voit notamment et il a combattu face au
commissaire qui a été interprété par
Louis de Funès et ça c'était dans les
années 60
un personnage masqué
personnage masqué
peut-être que Ludivine qui est juste
derrière à la réponse
[Musique]
oui c'est ça et voilà
les réponses et regarder cette extrait
c'est Fantômas
et un certain professeur le faire
professeur le 16 non le professeur le
fait c'est moi et je vois trois
professeurs Lefebvre avec Louis de Funès
[Musique]
mais non c'est pas ça
voilà il y a une quinzaine de films avec
Fantômas Fantômas qui a interprété par
Jean Marais et demain
voilà bon deuxième question un peu plus
facile est-ce que vous reconnaissez et
bien ces images
la maison Triolet
la question puisque Grégory a donné la
réponse effectivement Louis Aragon et
Elsa Triolet ont vécu dans cette maison
et aujourd'hui vous pouvez visiter cette
maison et découvrir le quotidien de
Louis Aragon et d'Elsa Triolet qu'on
voit en photo
effectivement de
Saint-Arnoult-en-Yvelines Grégory bravo
troisième question il est connu pour
être le premier auteur d'un roman de
science-fiction qui s'appelait les états
enfin qui s'appelle toujours les États
et empire de la Lune et du soleil mais
surtout pour avoir inspiré le personnage
principal d'une des pièces les plus
célèbres du répertoire français qu'elle
écrivain est né en 16 en 1619 pardon et
a passé son enfance au château de
mauvière à Saint-Forget alors pour vous
donner un indice c'est un personnage
célèbre d'une pièce de théâtre et qui a
inspiré justement le personnage de cette
pièce de théâtre question assez
compliqué
je donne ma langue au chat
si je vous dis de mon Rostand
de l'écrivain Savigny de Cyrano qui a
inspiré le personnage de Cyrano de
Bergerac et qui est et bien qui a passé
son enfance au château de mauvière à
Saint-Forget c'est tout près d'ici c'est
du côté et bien c'est juste après
château fort
quatrième question regardez ces images
nous sommes à l'abbaye de Port-Royal des
Champs
voilà l'abbaye de Pont Royal Deschamps
donc juste à côté de manie des hameaux
le château de la Madeleine à Chevreuse
voilà des images des courses de vélo
ce n'est pas une erreur de montage ça je
vous le dis mais la question ben c'est
la suivante quel est le célèbre drame
dramaturge et bien qui est réuni dans
toutes ces images
c'est réunit dans toutes ces images ces
images font référence à un célèbre
dramaturge français qui est ce célèbre
dramaturge
par rapport oui oui
Jean Racine effectivement j'en racine
donc
la course de vélo vous avez vu à l'image
s'appelle la course de la Jean Racine
parce que en fait j'en racine a vécu
pendant longtemps à l'abbaye de
Port-Royal Deschamps et passer notamment
pour aller jusqu'au château de la
Madeleine il y avait le chemin de Jean
Racine que on peut emprunter toujours à
l'heure actuelle et donc la course de
vélo qui a lieu que vous avez vu ces
images c'est dans la vallée de Chevreuse
cette course de vélo s'appelle la Jean
Racine c'est la course
du côté de l'abbaye de Port-Royal
cinquième question regardez ces images
nous sommes à la Villa Viardot à
Bougival
alors quel romancier nouvelle liste et
dramaturge née en 1818 en Russie auteur
de père et fils ou de mémoire d'un
chasseur et dont on a publié récemment
les correspondances avec Flaubert
intitulée je n'ai pas les nerfs assez
solides pour vivre dans ce monde a vécu
dans cette ville là
[Musique]
Bougival Pauline Viardot et en fait
c'était le mari hein tu as gagné non
exactement
Ivan tourgayer
écrivain russe donc était marié à Madame
diardo mais c'est vrai qu'on en avait
beaucoup parlé au moment du Loto du
patrimoine de la Villa Vierzon de ce
reportage en plus il mentionne les
sources de mes images Grégory bravo
c'est les archives de tv78 aussi
dernière question
des nouvelles images regardez cette
demeure un très joli château il est
situé au Port-Marly dans un espace dans
un espace à un forestier un peu caché
est-ce que vous pouvez me dire quel
écrivain a vécu dans ce château
alors c'est le château de Monte-Cristo
un indice Nicolas
est un indice je dis plus rien
Monte-Cristo
tement aucune idée
non Ludivine en coulisse
mais j'ai un truc mémoire
donc il s'agit d'Alexandre Dumas qui a
vécu dans cette demeure voilà bon il va
falloir réviser
en tout cas Nicolas de nous faire
réviser le jeudi mais je tire ces infos
de notamment de cet ouvrage voilà qui a
été réalisé par le Conseil départemental
des Yvelines et donc qui répertorie des
personnes célèbres qui sont passées ou
pion vécu dans le département des
Yvelines et puis je remercie aussi
Patrice carmouz notre notre directeur de
l'information qui m'a donné mais
aiguillé vers certaines réponses voilà